- [James] So,
I'm in the cubicle,
I'm a marketing manager for
Crestt Toothpaste--
- [Gary] Yes.
- [James] and
I'm like sick of it.
- [Gary] Yes.
- [James] And I
want to break out.
- [Gary] Yes.
- [James] Incomes
are going down.
I'm worried about my job.
- [Gary] Yes.
- [James] They're
outsourcing everything to China.
- [Gary] Yes.
- What should I start to do
or look at?
- The first thing you should do
is you shouldn't have fucking
watched "House of Cards"
this entire fucking Saturday.
That's the first
thing you should do.
- Okay.
- If you complain,
and by the way,
you could make $20,000 a
year and not be complaining.
So this is not about
how much success you've had.
This is complaining.
This is oh, wo is me.
I'm in this cubicle.
You're complaining to yourself
and even worse
and I know you guys,
you're complaining to others.
Your spouse, your girlfriend,
your brother, your mom.
If you are complaining,
the first thing that has to
happen is the elimination of
Madden, the softball team,
"House of Cards"
leisure!
Leisure is what
you give up to have
the audacity to build your life
that you want.
So, if you didn't
watch "House of Cards"
for 13 hours this weekend,
it would've given
you 13 hours to map out
what you're gonna do to get
out of that job at Crestt.
- [James] Yeah, Johnny Crestt
he eliminates "House of Cards",
eliminates the softball game,
he's ready to go. What's next?
- Self-awareness.
I believe that
self-awareness is the single
best number one attribute
anyone could
ever be gifted with.
Better than being good looking,
better than being super smart,
self-awareness.
I'm very comfortable in
admitting that I don't know
the science
behind self-awareness.
I don't know the anthropology or
psychology around it.
I don't know how it's taught.
(school bell rings)
I just know it's the thing
and then you do the assessment
and you take the data
and you finally for the first
time in your life,
Johnny Crestt,
decide you don't
live life hoping
and wishing you were something
you start for the
first time in your life
actually deciding what you are
and navigating around that.
So, Johnny Crestt does this.
Now, he starts to change.
He's like, "Okay, alright I want
to do bigger and better things
"in my life." What's next?
What's the next practical step?
'Cause that's a
good practical step.
- Well, I think at
that point Johnny Crestt
wants to decide if he
wants to go for it or not.
Because I actually think 8 out
of 10 times Johnny Crestt
after that process
takes a step back and says,
"You know what?
I like getting drunk
"with my buddies
on Thursday night.
"I like 'House of Cards.'
I think it's kinda cool."
And he then may realize, huh,
I'm actually okay.
Like yeah, I'm not
gonna be Mark--
- But let's say he's not.
- Okay, then he's not
then he decides what I think,
back to Crush It!, he tries to
build a business around
something he loves because if
he does that it won't be work.
Johnny's now 38.
Did we make him 38?
- [James] Let's make him 38.
- Johnny's now 38 and Johnny
watches NASCAR every weekend.
Johnny does mixed martial,
Johnny has to look
at what he does
when he's not working and build
a business around that.
Let's say Johnny,
15 years at Crestt,
let's say Johnny makes
$213,000 a year. Right?
What he has to do is decide is
he willing to make $87,000 a
year but be a shitload
happier and downsize his home
or not go on as many vacations.
These are choices, my man.
- It seems like
you're always leveraging
the thing you're doing,--
- [Gary] I am 'cause
I'm practical.
- for the next thing.
- [Gary] I'm scared, I'm
practical. I don't want.
The only advice I've
ever given in my life,
James, I'm super undereducated.
I was a D and F
student in high school,
I've read like four fucking
books and the only advice
I ever give is predicated on
things I've already done.
Let's talk
about a couple things.
There's a couple
things that I want
Johnny Crestt to do in parallel.
I want him to
create his Twitter account.
Twitter, even
though is struggling,
and it is. Still has a big
advantage over
every other platform.
Johnny Crestt can
absolutely type in
Pokemon or Rock 'N Roll
or UFC in Twitter search
and see other
people talking about it
and I want him to
engage with those people.
I also want him to
tweet at Dana White
and the creator of Pokemon
and PikachuGirl47 that's the
number one influencer on Twitter
and start creating
these relationships on social
because it's
part of the narrative.
In Twitter, they will see that
you're reaching out to them.
Now, PikachuGirl47 may
say I'm not talking to
Johnny Crestt but
if you do it 12 times,
you know, rewarding
you on that tenacity
and you start
building relationships.
And try to build of value.
Don't hit up
Pikachu47 and say,
"Hey, @PikachuGirl47
tell everybody about my
"Johnny Crestt Amazon account."
Watch Pikachu47
and when PikachuGirl47 says
that she needs something and you
happen to be in that town
be like, "I got you."
Bring value first.
- Right.
- We have to reprogram,
re-brand and re-look at
entrepreneurship.
Entrepreneurship is freedom.
It doesn't mean
making a million dollars.
It means freedom.
("The Price" by Jura Kez)